dia thought it would be nice to include
221st of a pound of chocolate in each of
the holiday gift bags she made for her
friends and family so dia is very
precise she wants exactly 221st of a
pound of chocolate how many how many
holiday gift bags could dia make with
two thirds of a pound of chocolate so we
really just need to think about what's
the total amount what's the total amount
of chocolate she has so what's the total
pounds and we just have to divide it by
the pounds she wants per bag pounds
pounds per bag and then you will get the
number of bags
number of
number of bags if she had six total
pounds and she wanted two pounds per bag
she would be able to make three bags and
so we just do the same thing over here
but over here her total number of pounds
it's a slightly hairier number it's
two-thirds so her total pounds are
two-thirds of a pound we want to divide
that by how many pounds she wants to put
in each bag so that would be 221st 221st
of a pound and this will give us the
number of bags now when we divide
fractions like this so we can rewrite
this expression this is the same thing
as
two-thirds
divided by
two twenty-first
two over twenty-one which we've learned
is the same thing as which is the same
thing as two-thirds two-thirds times the
reciprocal of two twenty-first which is
just twenty-one over two
twenty-one over two all we did is we
swapped the numerator and the
denominator we took the reciprocal here
when you divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by its reciprocal and this
is equal to and there's other videos
where we go into the idea behind that
we just have to multiply this out in our
numerator and i won't even multiply it
out in our numerator we get 2 times 21
i'll do a new color here 2 times 21 when
i multiply the numerators and the
denominator i get 3 times 2.
and now we can simplify it before we
even multiply it out divide the
numerator and denominator by a common
factor they're both divisible by two
they are both divisible by two so let's
divide both the numerator and
denominator by two and the numerator
denominator is both divisible by three
21's divided divisible by three and
three is divisible by three so let's
also divide them both
by three so when you divide the
numerator by two so this two and this
two cancels out and then 21 divided by
three you're just left with seven
down here you have two
divided by two cancels out and three
divided by 3 cancels out and so you're
left with 7 over 1 or exactly
7
7 bags